kay acotex su silla lidera proyectos
tecnológicos y educativos para generar
impacto social es todo un reto en japón
donde no es común ver a una mujer en
altos cargos gerenciales
y nacho y pretenden si
existe una tendencia a considerar mejor
a los hombres que a las mujeres no
sucede sólo desde la perspectiva
masculina también sucede desde la
perspectiva femenina es probable que
ellos están subestimando su propio valor
final respectivo por ser mujer cayaco
enfrenta problemas para conseguir
financiamiento
investment es muy difícil incluso a
nivel mundial sólo el 12 por ciento de
las mujeres en el mundo recibieron
financiamiento pero estar en japón es
aún más difícil perder el humor del
pecador la brecha no sólo se observa
financieramente también ocurre a nivel
gerencial
actualmente sólo hablamos de diversidad
y luego de igualdad de género hay una
división muy arraigada entre el hombre
profesional y las mujeres ocupando un
papel secundario cariaco recuerda su
primer entreno laboral en japón
allí los dividieron en dos grupos
el entrenamiento fue específicamente
sobre cómo sostener una bandeja y cómo
servir un té con cierto ángulo de los
codos y cómo hacer una reverencia
era sobre hospitalidad pero si hablamos
de la hospitalidad en una institución
financiera creo que hombres y mujeres
deben recibir la misma capacitación
sigman sirve de silanes siempre de
propiciar igualdad de entrenamientos son
los primeros pasos para ver un cambio en
japón y no uses ella en roboré ex canal
de los robots podrían reemplazar los
trabajos de medio tiempo muchos de ellos
realizados por mujeres
cuando esto suceda tenemos que darles
una capacitación adecuada a nivel
interprovincial cayaco trabaja en el
cambio inspira a mujeres a desarrollar
habilidades tecnológicas para el futuro
y así poder ocupar altos cargos en un
país gobernado por hombres